LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
de prime abord le télétravail semble
être une source de bien-être mais il
peut avoir de nombreux effets
indésirables le temps passé assis devant
un écran à augmenter et avec lui le
risque de souffrir d'une lombalgie de
troubles du sommeil ou de fatigue
visuelle ça peut être des maux de tête
ça va être l'envie de se gratter de se
frotter les yeux vraiment c'est une
teinte qui est quasi systématique le
manque de déconnexion de lien social et
les visioconférences à la chaîne ont
également eu des répercussions sur la
santé mentale des télétravailleurs
malgré le nombre et l'augmentation de
ces de ces réunions on a pu le voir à
distance
c'est pas ça qui rend forcément
l'isolement en un an le nombre de burn
out a été multiplié par deux alors
comment mieux prévenir ces risques
physiques et psychosociaux le
télétravail est-il vraiment bon pour la
santé c'est le thème de ce nouveau
numéro d'état de santé
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce numéro
d'état de santé même si les vacances
sont terminées vous l'avez peut-être
observées il y a pas mal de bureaux qui
sont restés vides parce qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de télétravail ce qui devait
être provisoire est en train de venir la
règle pour beaucoup est-ce que c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle quels
sont les impacts de ce télétravail en
termes de santé comment prévenir les
effets toxiques comment améliorer faire
en sorte que les télétravailleurs
évidemment en profitent au maximum en
termes de productivité pour les
employeurs mais aussi en termes de
plaisir au travail c'est de tout cela
dont on va parler avec Sylvain perragin
bonjour Sylvaine perragin bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on verra tout
à l'heure que vous êtes une spécialiste
du télétravail je vous pose la question
puis on va développer est-ce que c'est
une bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle en
termes de santé pour les
télétravailleurs alors je vais vous
faire une réponse de Normand pour
l'instant c'est les deux c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour beaucoup d'entre
eux et c'est une bonne nouvelle pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux il y a
énormément de gens qui ne veulent pas
tourner au travail et énormément de gens
qui ne veulent pas rester en télétravail
donc c'est intéressant c'est de
connaître les causes des deux et souvent
ce sont les mêmes personnes il y a une
contradiction intérieure entre j'ai pas
envie de retourner au bureau parce que
finalement je vais retrouver des
problèmes qui n'ont pas été résolus et
j'ai pas envie de rester chez moi parce
que travailler chez moi il y a tout un
tas de choses auxquelles je n'ai pas
accès et donc j'avais besoin et que
j'aimais bien à mon travail et quand on
ne revient pas au bureau parce qu'on n'a
pas envie parce que la salle ambiance
d'avant elle est toujours là on n'a pas
envie de se replonger en réalité le
télétravail à ce moment-là et bien ça
c'est pas une bonne solution exactement
c'est à dire qu'on règle une deuxième
cause et on ne s'attaque pas à la
première cause la première cause c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il y avait une
mauvaise ambiance au travail et quand on
aura résolu cette cause on pourra
négocier des jours de télétravail qui
seront des réels des réels avantages et
quelque chose de très positif alors
pourquoi vous êtes une spécialiste par
exemple du télétravail du côté des
salariés mais aussi du côté des
employeurs en votre portrait tout de
suite
Sylvaine perragin est psychothérapeute
et consultante en ressources humaines
depuis plus de 20 ans elle exerce donc à
la fois auprès des salariés et des
employeurs le monde de l'entreprise est
le connaît bien car elle y a travaillé
pendant 15 ans dans son livre le salaire
de la peine paru en 2019 aux éditions du
Seuil Sylvaine perragin dénonce les
dérives de la marchandisation de la
souffrance au travail aujourd'hui elle
s'inquiète des ravages du télétravail
sur la santé mentale
alors Steven perragin quelques questions
très simples déjà pour voir de quoi on
parle il y a eu beaucoup de d'idées
reçues qui sont installés on travaille
plus ou on travaille moins quand on est
en télétravail on a entendu tous les
sons contraires alors toutes les études
prouvent qu'on travaille plus on
travaille plus et à tout un tas de pause
qui n'existent plus
il y a une une intégration de la
nécessité d'atteindre les objectifs qui
est beaucoup plus importantes parce que
les gens ont l'impression que on compte
sur eux et donc l'intérieur
isation de l'objectif est encore plus
important qu'en présentiel
et et ils sont seuls avec eux-mêmes donc
c'est plus angoissant en fait alors on
va s'arrêter quelques instants en
chiffres sur les risques que comporte le
télétravail en termes physiques regardez
cette infographie
pour beaucoup d'entre nous
télétravailler c'est dire adieu au talon
aiguille à l'attaché Kais et au
transport bondé mais c'est aussi rester
assis lors du premier confinement un
tiers de la population a passé 7 heures
au minimum dans cette posture par jour
une augmentation pour 6 personnes sur 10
par rapport à l'avant confinement alors
bien au chaud dans le fond de nos
canapés sommes-nous à l'abri des dangers
pas si sûr lombalgie cervicalgie douleur
musculaires et tendinite guette nous en
avons plein le dos
pendant le premier confinement 10% des
travailleurs qui n'en souffraient pas
auparavant ont développé une lombalgie
côté cervicale c'est encore pire plus de
23% des télétravailleurs ont souffert de
douleurs qui ont même empiré au fil des
semaines pour la moitié d'entre eux mais
ça n'est pas tout les personnes
précédentes ont un risque sans douze
pour cent plus élevé de souffrir de
diabète que les personnes actives et un
risque cardiovasculaire 147% plus élevés
en Europe la sédentarité est ainsi
devenue la première cause de mortalité
évitable devant le tabac alors pour
prévenir ces risques peut-être
faudra-t-il faire plus de pause pendant
les journées de télétravail
remplacez 30 minutes de sédentarités
quotidiennes par 30 minutes d'activité
physique réduit de 17% la mortalité
prématurée
dans le télétravail nous ne sommes pas
tous dans des bonnes conditions
évidemment c'est pas du tout la même
chose d'être en train de travail dans
une maison de campagne avec lui pièces
et dans un deux pièces avec trois
enfants c'est pas du tout la même chose
donc les appartements surtout dans les
grandes villes ne sont pas du tout
conçues pour accueillir un lieu de
travail donc nous ne sommes pas égaux
moi j'ai beaucoup constaté que dans les
couples très rapidement c'était l'homme
qui prenait le dessus la femme
s'occupant de la maison des enfants etc
parce qu'elle sait faire parce que ça va
plus vite parce que parce que parce que
et puis les lieux les lieux physiques de
travail ne sont pas adaptés les chaises
ne sont pas adaptées pour accueillir des
gens pendant 8 heures assis sur une
chaise est-ce que les entreprises ont
une obligation
d'aider les salariés justement à adapter
leur poste de travail à la maison si
alors je crois que l'obligation est de
50 euros par mois pour les aider à
investir
dans des outils de travail adaptés mais
là il y a une négociation amenée qui est
importante quand même si on veut que les
gens restent en télétravail il va
falloir les aider à s'installer alors
une fois qu'on est assis on regarde son
écran oui on regarde son écran toute la
journée c'est ça ou alors son téléphone
évidemment et là on s'est interrogé dans
pour état de santé de savoir s'il y
avait un risque réel en ce qui concerne
la vision regardez c'est un reportage
qui va faire le tri entre le vrai et le
faux il est signé Marianne Cazaux
qui dit télétravail dit travail sur
écran mais nos meilleurs alliés de cette
année ont la mauvaise réputation de nous
abîmer les yeux
alors l'exposition aux écrans est-elle
aussi néfaste que le prétend de ces
articles pour le savoir direction
l'Institut de la vision au lieu de la
recherche en ophtalmologie
ici des yeux d'animaux sont disséqués
afin de ne conserver que la rétine
l'objectif l'exposer à la lumière et
observer sa réaction
Serge Picot a travaillé sur cette étude
voici les cellules de la rétine
auxquelles il s'est intéressé donc en
fait c'est vraiment des photorécepteurs
isolées c'est neurones sensibles à la
lumière et à sa toxicité ont été exposés
à ces différentes couleurs qui composent
le spectre du soleil violet bleu ou
rouge les effets sur les yeux ne sont
pas les mêmes lorsqu'on expose ses
photos récepteurs à la lumière on voit
que si on les expose à la lumière bleue
violette ici vers 4340 nanomètres les
cellules disparaissent elles meurt alors
que si on les expose à de la lumière
verte ou bleu turquoise en fait ces
cellules survivent très bien donc ça
montre bien que cette lumière est très
toxique pour les photos récepteurs si
vous perdez vos photos récepteurs dans
la mesure où ce sont des neurones ils ne
sont pas capables de se renouveler donc
vous perdez ces cellules et si vous
perdez tous vos photos récepteurs dans
une zone et bien vous devenez aveugle
dans cette zone d'après les
expérimentations que Serge Picot a
effectuées ici les Parisiens peuvent
être exposés à un tel niveau de toxicité
des rayons en août les jours ensoleillés
cette lumière bleue violette est aussi
émise par nos écrans d'ordinateurs mais
même lorsque le ciel est nuageux comme
aujourd'hui son intensité reste bien
plus faible que celle du soleil entre la
toxicité de la lumière et la toxicité
des écrans je pense qu'il y a un
amalgame qui est c'est un peu fait les
écrans a priori ne sont pas être le
coupable dans la toxicité de la lumière
il faut plutôt regarder du côté du
soleil et bien se protéger avec des
lunettes de soleil
en effet aucune étude scientifique n'a
prouvé que la lumière émise par les
écrans d'ordinateur est toxiques janss
recommande simplement de entre
guillemets limiter l'exposition des
populations et en particulier des
enfants à la lumière riche en bleu avant
le coucher et pendant la nuit pour
éviter les troubles du sommeil
en y regardant de plus près nous
remarquons que les articles les plus
alarmistes étaient en fait des publis
rédactionnels signés de la main d'une
marque de verre anti lumière bleue il
s'agit donc d'une fausse piste la
lumière émise par les écrans
d'ordinateur n'en dommage pas notre vue
pourtant depuis plus d'un an les
télétravailleurs sont nombreux dans les
salles d'attentes des ophtalmologistes
alors si le problème ne vient pas de la
lumière bleue d'où vient-il généralement
les gens nous disent que maintenant ils
passent une majorité de leur journée en
fait devant l'écran et que ils ont
remarqué en fait qu'ils avaient donc une
fatigue oculaire donc qui englobe pas
mal de choses qui est une plainte assez
floue mais qui va falloir explorer ça
peut être des maux de tête ça va être
l'envie de se gratter de se frotter les
yeux c'était une teinte qui était moins
rapportée avant le confinement et depuis
le la fin du confinement et l'expansion
du télétravail vraiment c'est quelque
chose qui est quasi systématique et face
à ces symptômes là cette fois-ci il n'y
a pas de doute c'est bien lui le
responsable les scientifiques par le
même d'un syndrome de l'écran
d'ordinateur le nombre de publications
sur le sujet d'ailleurs explosé en 2020
et en 2021
les symptômes sont passagers mais
peuvent être désagréables ils ne sont
pas liés à la lumière bleue mais le plus
souvent à une mauvaise installation du
poste de travail si cet écran est un
petit peu trop haut le problème de cet
écran trop fait que on va ouvrir les
yeux beaucoup plus grands et qu'on va
cligner en fait beaucoup moins
fréquemment et donc ça ça va induire en
fait une sécheresse de la surface
oculaire et qui va pouvoir donc gêner
les patients donc idéalement il faut
avoir un écran qui est à sa hauteur ou
un petit peu plus bas que soi pour
essayer d'avoir un clignement qui est
relativement optimal
plus le temps passé devant les écrans
est long plus la sensation de sécheresse
et la fatigue oculaire peuvent survenir
pour éviter ces désagréments il faut
donc savoir faire des pauses pendant sa
journée de télétravail et se passer de
temps en temps de son écran
bon madame Perlin on est à moitié
rassuré sur les séquelles à long terme
mais quand même ça a des effets ça n'a
pas des effets que sur la vision le
télétravail et surtout le fait qu'on
soit fixé sur l'écran en permanence il y
a d'autres conséquences possibles que
vous avez identifié oui absolument il y
a une fatigue mentale ça crée une
fatigue mentale c'est-à-dire une fatigue
de la concentration les gens n'arrivent
plus à se concentrer et ça c'est une
surconsommation d'écran mais comment on
va faire parce que le télétravail pour
une partie des salariés sans doute on ne
reviendra pas dessus alors il faut
rappeler que maintenant les entreprises
ont la main elles n'ont plus
d'obligation de mettre à cause du covid
deux jours par semaine leur salarié en
télétravail elles font ce qu'elle veut
il va y avoir des négociations qu'est-ce
que vous préconisez alors je préconise
qu'on réfléchisse bien à ce que
l'entreprise et les salariés veulent en
termes de relations au travail parce que
si on garde le télétravail on atomise
le collectif de travail est-ce que une
entreprise va continuer à faire
entreprise alors que ces salariés sont
chez eux et ils vont se voir Martine le
lundi Christophe le mercredi donc ne se
rencontrerons pas parce que le but c'est
du télétravail c'est de rationaliser les
espaces de travail vous savez bien qu'il
y a énormément d'entreprises qui ont
vendu arrêter de louer des étages de
bureau des des mètres carrés de bureau
donc qui ont fait beaucoup d'économistes
tant mieux pour elle c'est pas la
question simplement tout ça a des
conséquences une des choses que l'être
humain avait un chercher au travail
c'est la relation c'est vraiment la
relation et dans la relation se joue
énormément de choses ça va se jouer vont
se jouer un la qualité du travail va se
jouer
l'appréciation de la relation humaine
c'est à dire que c'est une des choses
qu'on vient chercher des relations
sociales est-ce que l'entreprise en tant
quantité est encore une entreprise si
tout le monde est en télétravail donc
proscrire c'est votre préconisation
évidemment le télétravail à 100%. alors
il y a le problème dans le problème si
veut dire il y a la question des écrans
et puis après et qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
et là on va s'intéresser à la réunionite
il y a des effets secondaires qui sont
liés à la visioconférence on va regarder
ça c'est important de Marianne Caseau
Jessie 27 ans est artiste pour des jeux
vidéos un vrai digital native né avec
Internet travailler pendant plusieurs
heures devant un écran ne lui fait pas
peur et le télétravail a priori non plus
mais il y a une chose qu'il n'avait pas
anticipé les visioconférences
après deux heures de réunion à distance
il n'en peut plus et il n'a même pas
encore commencé sa véritable journée de
travail la création après une longue
vision conférence
fatigué quoi vraiment fatigué du mal à
se concentrer du mal à continuer en fait
à enchaîner tout de suite sur quelque
chose enfin des tâches en cours en plus
ça peut vraiment te perturber si tu
faisais quelque chose déjà et que tu
commences une visio et que bah après
pour reprendre la route en été enfin
c'est difficile en voulant être sûr que
tout le monde travaille on met un frein
au travail des gens et c'est pas
forcément aussi assez frustrant
Jessy n'est pas le seul à ressentir
cette lassitude bien spécifique les
médias lui ont même donné un nom la Zoom
fatigue zoom c'est le nom de la
plateforme de visioconférence la plus
utilisée et même son PDG a avoué qu'il
avait lui-même expérimenté cette forme
d'épuisement
mais alors qu'y a-t-il de si particulier
avec des réunions à distance pour le
comprendre et bien le mieux c'est de se
mettre en condition c'est donc par
visio-conférence que nous contactons
l'une des premières chercheuses à avoir
étudié la Zoom fatigue
une fois que vous êtes en
visioconférence tout ce que je peux voir
de vous c'est les épaules et la tête et
donc ça crée deux problèmes tout d'abord
je vais essayer de comprendre vos
comportements non verbaux mais cela va
me demander un effort cognitif
supplémentaire vu que je n'ai que une
petite fenêtre sur sur vous alors dans
l'autre dans l'autre sens pour que je
puisse communiquer mes comportements
vers vous et être certaine que vous les
percevez je vais devoir les accentuer
donc par exemple si vous dites quelque
chose et que je suis d'accord je vais
acquiescer comme ça plus longtemps et
plus fort que je ne le ferai si on était
l'une à côté de l'autre lors d'une
conversation à distance il nous manque
donc tous ces signaux non verbaux mais
aussi tous les à côté des réunions que
l'on appelle aujourd'hui en présentiel
malgré le nombre et l'augmentation de
ces de ces réunions on a pu le voir à
distance
c'est pas ça qui rend forcément
l'isolement donc en tant que tel c'est
important que les salariés puissent
participer à des réunions collectives
mais ça ne suffit pas parce que ce n'est
pas forcément la dynamique dans laquelle
les gens veulent pouvoir partager
échanger avoir des retours sur leur
travail et je crois que ce qui est
important c'est de pouvoir avoir des
moments qui soient plus informels en
tant que tel conviviaux spontané
l'absence de ces contacts physiques
prive notre cerveau d'une source de
bien-être essentielle par exemple une
simple poignée de mains entre collègues
stimule la libération d'hormones et
parmi elles l'ocytocine la dopamine et
la sérotonine qui agit sur l'humeur et
le stress
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
Christophe Nguyen mène de nombreuses
enquêtes auprès des salariés français
pour mesurer leur niveau de détresse
psychologique en particulier chez les
télétravailleurs plus exposés au risque
psychosociaux et il y a urgence
on a eu le taux de Burn Out par exemple
qui a augmenté x 2 quoi
quasiment deux fois plus en un an c'est
pourquoi selon lui il faut se tourner
vers les entreprises aujourd'hui il
prend des nouvelles d'une équipe de
ressources humaines qu'il a accompagné
cette année par visioconférence dans
cette entreprise la rentrée et le moment
de remettre à plat la pratique en dehors
de cette parenthèse de crise sanitaire
qui oblige les salariés à être le plus
possible à distance on va définir un
mode de travail qui sera régulier et
donc il faut continuer à accompagner les
managers pour pousser la réflexion avec
leur équipe à l'avenir les
visioconférences pourraient être moins
nombreuses dans certaines sociétés mais
encore faut-il qu'elles prennent
conscience des risques psychosociaux du
télétravail et ce n'est pas gagné deux
salariés sur trois pensent que les
entreprises n'assument pas les
conséquences des dégâts psychologiques
qu'elle provoque
bon voilà ça s'appelle la Zoom fatigue
vous étiez au courant j'imagine
est-ce que par exemple ça il faut
demander aux entreprises de faire moins
de réunions oui oui clairement très
simplement et très précisément oui il
faut faire moindre réunion alors c'est
valable aussi en présentiel on est bien
d'accord parce que la réunioni est date
pas de zoom en revanche moi j'accompagne
des entreprises j'ai vu des gens qui
avaient huit réunions dans une journée
c'est intenable si vous laissez
intenable est-ce que les managers ont
conscience de ça c'est difficile de
mettre tous les managers dans le même
sac si vous voulez il y a des gens qui
ont tout à fait conscience et avec qui
ça se passe très bien justement parce
qu'ils sont intelligents ouvert d'esprit
qui sont au courant de ce qui se passe
parce qu'ils le vivent et puis vous avez
tout un tas de managers qui sont
absolument pas au courant et qui est et
ce qui se joue dans ce que vous décrivez
c'est le contrôle du travail
une distance psychologique avec leur
travail donc le sentiment d'appartenance
il diminue donc le degré de liberté
augmente et et c'est pour ça qu'on voit
beaucoup de démission on voit beaucoup
de gens qui partent
qui démissionnent qui négocient des
ruptures conventionnelles mais qui
quittent leur boulot qui profitent de
cette qui ont profité de cette pandémie
pour se dire non mais finalement ça ne
me convient pas ce travail ne me
convient on révélateur absolument ça
c'est un bon révélateur
ça veut dire que les problèmes pour les
raisons quoi bien sûr pour les résoudre
si j'ai 20% d'augmentation de départ
peut-être qu'il y a quelque chose à
confronter est-ce que la médecine du
travail est bien formée au risque du
télétravail alors la médecine du travail
je vais essayer de pas être trop
caricatural mais moi ça fait 20 ans que
je fréquente des médecins du travail
j'ai dû en rencontrer deux qui étaient à
la hauteur de leur métier donc
ah oui c'est rude oui c'est très rude
mais franchement ils sont pas formés moi
je travaille sur les risques
psychosociaux ils n'y connaissent
absolument rien on a déjà consacré une
émission à la médecine du travail ils
sont pas formés donc là on vient de
sortir une loi où il parle de formation
des salariés mais qui commence par
former les médecins du travail sur les
risques psychosociaux par exemple le
télétravail il va sans doute se
pérenniser pour une partie des
probablement des salariés vous aviez dit
très important c'est que l'employeur
fasse confiance aux salariés c'est pas
parce qu'il l'a pas sous la main qui
doit pas lui faire confiance au
contraire doit réinvestir de la
confiance et la base de ça on va
conclure là dessus c'est qu'il faut des
règles claires entre l'employeur et son
salarié pour organiser le télétravail
c'est le Beaba ça non absolument des
règles claires et surtout et c'est là où
les formations sont importantes si vous
voulez aider médecins du travail et des
syndicats et des anciens CHSCT qui
s'appelle maintenant ces deux SCT et des
CSE et des managers et des employeurs
tout le monde doit être formé au réel
enjeux de ce télétravail et des hommes
et des femmes politiques également qui
feraient bien de se former aux réelles
enjeux que de la santé au travail qui
est une vraie problématique de société
si vous voulez au-delà des divergences
politiques c'est une vraie problématique
de société donc il faut que les chefs
d'entreprise les managers et les
salariés se forment pour discuter des
réels problèmes et pas juste de la
périphérie de des conséquences et là
dans cette loi on est sur la périphérie
et sur les conséquences et c'est dommage
parce que c'était vraiment l'occasion
d'en discuter de manière plus aiguë plus
précise plus efficace pour terminer vous
vous avez fait du télétravail avec vos
clients et vos patients ou
psychothérapies en psychothérapie j'ai
fait alors au début je suis passé en ce
que je j'avais pas envie de faire je
suis j'ai fait de la visio et puis je me
suis rapidement aperçue que c'était pas
du tout confortable j'étais pas du tout
à l'aise il y a quelque chose qui
n'allait pas donc je suis assez
rapidement passée au téléphone je trouve
que la voix est beaucoup plus libre par
téléphone et j'entends beaucoup plus de
choses et beaucoup plus finement par
téléphone que une image qui est figée et
qui finalement faussait la relation plus
de choses de la personnalité de l'état
de la personne et de son intention par
la seule voie oui par le seul support de
la voix que par en tout cas c'est très
intéressant merci infiniment Steven
pergin d'avoir été avec nous merci de
nous avoir suivi dans ce numéro d'état
de santé et à très vite sur LCP
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé